умрут все,
вообще все. И ты, и я. Вот только есть
на свете люди,
которым удалось умереть дважды. Терри
Уильямс, двадцатилетний фермер из
Арканзаса. Я бы даже сказал, типичный
фермер в нашем представлении. В колледж
подступить Тери не смог, поэтому остался
в родном городе. Присматривал за
свиньями на ферме, чинил машины.
Влюбился Тери в семнадцатилетнюю Сэнди.
Родителям Терри Сэнди не понравилось, но
затем девушка забеременела, и свадьбу
всё же сыграли. В июне восемьдесят
четвёртого у пары родилась дочь Эмбер, а
через месяц жизнь семьи изменилась
навсегда.
13 июля восемьдесят четвётого года.
Пятница тринадцатая. Терри вместе с
другом сел в свой пикап и уехал по
делам, а по пути не справился с
управлением. Грузовик перевернулся,
пробил ограждение и рухнул в реку.
Наступила полная тьма.
Терри проснулся в больнице. Первое, кого
он увидел, была медсестра. А первое, что
он произнёс, было: "Можно Pepси".
Идеальная была бы реклама. Медсестра тут
же засуетилась, побежала за врачами.
Терри сообщили, что сейчас к нему придут
родственники. И пока пациент приходил в
себя, в палату вошла девушка. лет так
двадцати. Красивая. Терри её не узнал, а
затем ему объяснили, что девушку зовут
Эмбер. Ей 19 лет, и она его дочь.
В тот день, 13 июля восемьдесят
четвёртого года, пикап Терри
перевернулся и упал с моста в воду. Друг
погиб на месте. Сам Терри сутки пролежал
в кустах, пока случайный прохожий его не
нашёл. Парня доставили в больницу,
прооперировали. Однако мозг был слишком
сильно повреждён. Уилис впал в кому.
Родителям говорили: "Надеяться не на
что. С такой травмой просто не
выживают". Родственники всё равно
настояли не отключать его от аппарата
жизнедеятельности. Тогда парня перевели
в дом престарелых. В медицинской
страховке семьи отказали, потому что
врачи сказали, что парень буквально
живой труп. А зачем платить за труп?
Жена Тери за это время нашла нового
мужчину и родила от него трёх детей. А
спустя 19 лет Терри проснулся.
Как построить свою жизнь спустя 19 лет
комы? Все близкие постарели, а ты не
узнаёшь окружающий мир.
Что видели люди, испытавшие клиническую
смерть? И почему многие из них начинают
верить в загробную жизнь?
Как объяснить случаи, когда люди после
комы начинали говорить на другом языке
или начинали предсказывать будущее?
И как быть, если впал в кому один
человек, а вышел из неё? Как будто уже
совершенно другой?
[музыка]
Июнь 2003 года. Анжелла, мать Тери, как
обычно приехала в дом престарелых
Маутенви. Зашла в палату, и медсестра
уже, как обычно, на автомате сказала
Терри. Терри, посмотри, как кто к нам
пришёл. А Терри, спустя 19 лет молчания,
внезапно сказал: "Мама". А затем
попросил баночку коллы. Мама вспоминает:
"Я тут же бросилась и принесла ему
банку. Это растиражировало телевидение.
Владельцы торговой марки получили
бесплатную рекламу". Вот мужик только
пришёл в себя после 19 лет комбы и сразу
просит наш напиток. Мы попытались с них
вытрясти хоть что-то, но они на отрез
отказались платить. Мама ещё и
попробовала заработать на том, что сын
проснулся. Парень сел в машину
девятнадцатилетним,
а проснулся тридцативлетним.
Своих родителей он сразу узнал, хоть и
очень сильно постаревших. А вот дочь,
разумеется, нет. Когда он попал в
аварию, ей был один месяц. Сейчас ей 19
лет. Ещё его расстроил тот факт, что на
момент пробуждения она работала
стриптизёршей и к тому же была
беременна. Решили, так сказать, добить
парня. Все родственники постарели на 20
лет. Кого-то уже не стало. Мир вокруг
Терри 20 лет развивался. и жил без него.
Первый месяц после возвращения в жизнь
Терри находился в шоковом состоянии. Он
постоянно повторял одно и то же: "Этого
не может быть". Парень стал настоящей
медицинской сенсацией. После 20 лет комы
мало кто просыпается. Я бы даже сказал,
почти никто. Врачи давно поставили на
нём крест. Но уже через 3 недели после
пробуждения мужчина почти полностью
восстановил речь, проводил время с
дочерью и родившейся внучкой. Через
полтора года Терри начал двигать
парализованными конечностями. Тем не
менее, у Уилиса были очень сильно
повреждены когнитивные функции. Он мог
забыть то, что произошло с ним 5 минут
назад. Ослабли мышцы. Он не мог
самостоятельно есть, и у него были
сильные дефекты речи. Всю оставшуюся
жизнь он был прикован к инвалидному
креслу. Из интересных особенностей у
Тери после комы полностью исчезло
ощущение сытости. Он ел и не чувствовал
насыщения. приходилось искусственно
останавливать себя, так сказать, на
глаз. Мне кажется, если бы у меня не
было ощущения сытости, я бы умер, ну,
прямо сегодня. Доктор, который лечил
Терис восемьдесят четвёртого года,
говорил: "Этот случай просто
экстраординарный. Я назвал бы его чудом,
которое невозможно объяснить. Мне
кажется, что его спасла любовь родных.
Они заботились о нём все эти годы. Он
никогда не переставал быть частью их
семьи. Ведь в основном, к сожалению,
если нет никаких улучшений, впавший в
Хму отключают от системы
жизнеобеспечения. Терри Уильямс умер
совсем недавно, 29 марта 2022 года, за 9
дней до своего пятидесятивосьмилетия,
треть своей жизни Терри пропустил. Он
впал в кому молодым, а проснулся старым.
А в следующей истории, в точности
наоборот, мужчина впал в кому старым, а
проснулся молодым. Лучиана Дадама,
итальянский музыкант и композитор,
родился в пятьдесят четвёртом году,
выступал в римских музыкальных группах.
К 50 годам занялся ещё и преподаванием
музыки в музыкальных училищах. А в 2014
году, когда мужчине было 60 лет, Лучиану
попал в страшнейшую аварию. Виновником
был другой водитель, который скрылся с
места преступления, и его так и не
удалось поймать. Адама пролежал в Коме
несколько недель, а когда вышел, он
просто забыл 40 лет своей жизни. Он
попал в аварию, когда ему было 60, а
когда проснулся, искренне верил, что ему
около двадцати. Он думал, что сейчас
восьмидесятый год. Он помнил все события
до восьмидесятого года. Все последующие
события он просто забыл. Когда
композитор проснулся, его спросили:
"Кему из родственников хотите
позвонить?" Он ответил: "Маме". дали ему
телефон, и Лучана удивился. Что это за
странный предмет? Он просто не знал, как
им пользоваться. Хотя это был его
телефон. Но самое страшное ждало его
впереди, потому что матери уже давно не
было в живых. Мне было 23, и я хотел
поскорее уехать. У меня не было
серьёзных травм, только небольшая
путаница в голове, так думал я. Затем в
палату вошёл ещё один взрослый мужчина и
назвал Лучьяно папой. Вот это
сумасшедший, подумал я. Ему должно быть
лет 30. Как он может быть моим сыном,
если мне 23? Ну и главный шок Лучина в
тот день, то, что он увидел в зеркале. Я
подхожу к зеркалу и смотрю на человека,
который в нём отражается. Это пожилой
джентльмен. Не я, это кто-то другой. Я
начинаю кричать. Приходят медсёстры и
пытаются меня успокоить. Я был в ужасе.
Это было похоже на настоящий хоррор.
Врачи не могли объяснить, что со мной
происходит. Они сказали мужчине, имеется
в виду сыну, что это пройдёт, что нужно
просто набраться терпения. Что касается
личной жизни, последние воспоминания
Лучиану - это то, что он влюблён в
девятнадцатилетнюю девушку и даже хочет
сделать ей предложение. А когда он
проснулся, ему сказали, что они уже в
браке с этой девушкой 40 лет и у них
двое сыновей. Более того, странная
ситуация сложилась. Его старшему сыну
больше 30 лет, а сам Луьна себя ощущал
на 24. То есть, по его ощущениям, его
сын был старше него. Лучина так и живёт
двадцатитрёхлетним парнем. Семья
рассказывает ему его жизнь. Иногда у
него в памяти происходят вспышки
воспоминаний, но лишь иногда. Иногда я
говорю, что хотел бы полетать на
самолёте. Я этого никогда не делал. Моя
жена говорит мне: "О чём ты говоришь? Мы
вместе были в Париже." И я отвечаю: "Ты
была там?" Я: "Нет". Сейчас Лучино
работает в школе. Что интересно, он до
сих пор не получил компенсацию за
несчастный случай и вообще не помнит и
не понимает, что произошло. Я
несчастлив. Я не могу быть счастлив. Я
узнал, что моя мать умерла, и я даже не
помню, когда был на её похоронах. Я
понял, что жизнь - это только
воспоминания. Страшные истории. Очень
страшные люди мгновенно просыпаются
старыми, пропустив всю свою жизнь. Но
следующая история ещё страшнее. Или вот
другой случай из России. Мужчина 33 лет
описывает свои воспоминания во время
клинической смерти. Сначала я как будто
вылетел из тела. Я видел, как доктора
вокруг меня суетились, но я не
чувствовал страха. Затем вспышка.
Я несусь по белому яркому туннелю, а
затем оказываюсь в раю.
Это место мне знакомо. Мне было там
спокойно и безопасно. Я видел ангелов.
Они как будто парили над землёй. Они
помогали всем, кто нуждается в помощи.
Мне даже не нужно было говорить. Они
понимали всё без слов. А ещё у них очень
удобное приложение.
Да, это фитсервис. И у них действительно
очень удобное приложение с прозрачной
документацией. Здесь действительно
спокойно и безопасно,
как в раю.
Работники Фитсервиса помогут в любой
ситуации, всё объяснят и расскажут. Вот
только летать они на самом деле не
умеют. А попасть сюда можно менее
экстремальным путём. Уже открыто больше
300 станций в более чем 160 городах
мира. Приходите и вы.
Записывайтесь на бесплатную диагностику
ходовой по ссылке в описании. Мартин
Писториус родился 31 декабря семьдесят
пятого года в Южной Африке. Обычно
ребёнок очень увлекался точными науками
и техническими задачами. Пишет, что в 11
лет он чинил дома розетки. Мне, кстати,
до сих пор туда страшно лазить. А чтобы
защитить свои игрушки от брата с
сестрой, он установил сигнализацию в
своей комнате. Нифига себе. А в 12 лет
мальчик начал жаловаться на боль в
горле. Больше в школу он не ходил. Его
здоровье начало резко ухудшаться. Он
перестал есть, ему стало больно ходить.
Он стал забывать, что было 5 минут
назад, затем перестал узнавать лица
близких ему людей. Мартин стал забывать,
кто он сам. Свои последние слова он
произнёс в больнице. Мам, когда домой?
Пальцы рук и ног мальчика скрючились.
Тело его не слушалось. Единственное, что
он мог делать сам - глотать еду. Врачи
не смогли поставить точный диагноз. Они
только предположили. Криптоковый
минингит или туберкулёз головного мозга.
Он впал в так называемую бодрствующую
кому. Глаза мальчика были открытыми, он
вращал ими, но взгляд не фокусировался.
Доктора развели руками и сообщили
родителям, что мальчик, скорее всего,
уже не проснётся и долго он не проживёт.
Мать Джуан уволилась с работы, стала
ухаживать за сыном. Когда мальчику
исполнилось 14, родители каждый день
возили его в больницу, в стационар
временного пребывания. Отец каждое утро
мыл и одевал сына, отвозил в больницу,
затем и сам ехал на работу. Ночью каждые
несколько часов он просыпался и
переворачивал Мартина, чтобы у того не
возникали прорежни. А затем в семье
Писториус начали происходить ссоры. Мать
после очень долгой депрессии приняла для
себя, что сын больше не проснётся.
Доктора её убедили в этот. Более того, у
семьи было ещё двое детей. Е мать просто
испугалась, что, ухаживая за Мартином,
она пропустит взросление других детей.
Она уговаривала отца поместить Мартина в
спецнтернат постоянного пребывания, но
отец отказывался. Он продолжал
практически всё своё свободное от работы
время уделять на сына. А одна из сон
родителей случилась прямо в палате
Мартина. Тогда Джуан в слезах
повернулась к сыну и сказала: "Ты должен
умереть. Ты обязан умереть",
подразумевая то, что семья должна жить
дальше. 1998 год. В интернат, где лежал
Мартин, устраивается на работу молодая
девушка по имени Вирна. У неё была
привычка. Она общалась со своими
пациентами, которые лежали в коме.
Каждый день она приходила в палату и
рассказывала Мартину о своей жизни, что
с ней сегодня произошло, какие планы на
вечер. Она смотрела с ним телевизор и
комментировала всё, что происходит на
экране. И вот однажды она заметила, что
когда она задаёт Мартину вопросы, тот
начинает неровно дышать. Он начинает
резко выдыхать воздух. Она попробовала
ещё несколько раз, и каждый раз Мартин
выдыхал воздух на вопросе. Такого
совпадения просто не могло быть. А это
значит, что Мартин всё понимал. Верно
рассказал об этом родителям. Мартина
отвезли в Центр альтернативных методов
коммуникации в университете Притории.
Там уже, кстати, взрослый Мартин прошёл
тестирование. Он задерживал взгляд на
нужных картинках, правильно указывал на
те иные предметы. Теперь доктора точно
были уверены, Мартин в сознании, он
просто парализовы. Его подключили к
специальному компьютеру, который
позволял медленно, но всё же общаться. И
тогда вскрылась страшная правда. Мартин
практически всё это время был в
сознании.
Мальчик впал в кому в возрасте 14 лет, а
в 16 лет вышел из неё. Вот только
управлять своим телом он не мог. Он
полностью осознавал всё, что происходит.
Всё видел, всё слышал, но двигаться не
мог. Он был заперт в своём теле. Он
чётко всё осознавал. Он даже следил за
новостями, когда их показывали по
телевизору. А ещё он очень сильно
ненавидел телепередачу Барни и его
друзья из-за постоянных повторов одного
и того же. А попросить переключить он
просто не мог. Врачи относились к
Мартину как к растению. Они и подумать
не могли, что он способен мыслить. А
один из самых страшных дней Мартина был
тот самый день, когда родители
поссорились прямо у него в палате. Тогда
мама, глядя ему в глаза, сказала те
самые: "Ты должен умереть".
И лишь спустя 9 лет, аж 9 лет, он был
заперт в своём теле. Появилась верно.
Медсестра, которая и заметила
странности. Парня начали лечить, и он
постепенно начал приходить в себя. С
помощью компьютера он научился звонить
по телефону, отправлять письма, начинал
постепенно двигаться. Более того, он
нашёл работу в коммуникационном центре,
а в июне 2009 года он даже женился на
подружке своей сестры. К тому моменту
правая сторона тела Мартина настолько
восстановилась, что он уже смог водить
машину, а в конце 2018 года он стал
родителем. В 2011 году Мартин выпустил
книгу Гостбой Мальчик-Пвидения. И теперь
на ум приходит одна мысль. Интересно, а
сколько сейчас пациентов на самом деле в
сознании? Знаете, кома, клиническая
смерть - это последствия очень серьёзных
травм и зачастую травм мозга. А мы с
вами это и есть наш мозг. То, какие мы,
какой у нас характер определяет наш
мозг. И после таких травм люди часто
возвращаются с того света уже немного
другими людьми. И я говорю не просто о
потере концентрации, понижении каких-то
физических качеств. Часто возвращается
действительно совершенно другой человек.
2015 год, Германия.
Восьмидесятиоднолетний
дедушка переносит ишемический инсульт.
Имя пациента не называют из врачебной
тайны. Дедушка пролежал в коме несколько
недель, а когда очнулся, его поведение
очень сильно изменилось. Сначала
дезориентация, он не сразу узнавал
родных, эмоциональная расторможенность,
случались приступы беспричинного
внезапного смеха или агрессии, а ещё
гиперсексуальность.
Восьмидесятиоднолетний
женатый дед начал приставать к
медсёстрам. иногда раздевался прямо в
палате при посетителях, ну и занимался
различными
другими непотребствами. Только через 3
месяца гиперсексуальность снизилась, но
не исчезла полностью. У этого
расстройства есть название синдром
Клювера Bю. Возникает из-за повреждения
височных долей мозга. Вместе с
гиперсексуальностью часто появляется
гипероральность, стремление брать в рот
несъедобные предметы, а также
эмоциональная притупленность, отсутствие
страха или гнева. 13 сентября 1848
года двадцатипятилетний Финиас Гейдж,
работавший бригадиром строителей
железной дороги в Вермонте, готовил
взрывчатку для прокладки пути. В
результате взрывчатка случайно
сдетонировала, и металлический пруд
диаметром 3 см, пробив череп Финиаса,
вошёл ему в голову под левой скулой и
вышел с обратной стороны. До травмы
Гейдж описывался как ответственный,
уравновешенный и решительный.
А ещё коллеги замечали, что у него было
потрясающее чувство юмора. После травмы
его описывали как импульсивный и грубый,
и он стал очень часто материться. В 2002
году 30дцатилетний Джейсон Педжет,
бывший продавец мебели, был жестоко
избит грабителями возле караоки бара в
такоми США. Сотрясение мозга, потеря
сознания. А после травмы, когда он
пришёл в себя, он стал настоящим
математическим гением. У него появились
навязчивые образы геометрических фигур.
Всё вокруг стало состоять из линий и
геометрических фигур. Он внезапно понял
высшую математику, хотя раньше он в
принципе плохо считал. А также он развил
синестезию. Числа и формулы стали
визуализироваться в его сознании как
красивые геометрические паттерны. Он
получил степень в математике и стал
лектором. Его мозг исследовали с помощью
МРТ в центре изучения разума при
университете Калифорнии. Диагноз,
приобретённый савантизмом, с
визуально-пространственной синестезией.
И это, конечно, удивительно, то есть
после травмы мозг как-то активизировал
свои зоны или перепрограммировал, что он
получил уникальные способности. Но это
всё с точки зрения науки довольно
объяснимо. А как быть со случаями,
которые вы, наверное, слышали, в которых
рассказывалось, что люди после того, как
вышли из комы, заговорили на других
языках?
Самый известный, задокументированный
случай - это Бен Макмахн. Родился в 1991
году в Мельбурне, Австралия. Работал в
гостиничном сервисе. В 2009 году, когда
Бену было 18 лет, он ехал в машине с
друзьями. Водитель не справился с
управлением, и автомобиль врезался в
дерево. Бен получил очень тяжёлые травмы
головы и грудной клетки. На несколько
минут его сердце остановилось, и врачи
констатировали клиническую смерть. Тогда
его откачали, но Бен впал в кому, а
когда он очнулся, первое, что он сказал
было: "Извините, где я нахожусь? Только
на китайском".
Врачи китайского не знали и думали, что
это какой-то дефект речи. Но когда в
больницу позвали носителя китайского,
тот подтвердил: Бен говорит на
мандаринском диалекте, официальный
китайский язык. И вот тут начинается
путаница. Когда родителям сказали, что
их сын заговорил на китайском, они
ответили, что Бен учил китайский в
школе. Но его знания были довольно
поверхностными. В таком случае тот факт,
что Бен вспомнил китайский, довольно
объяснимо. Но в некоторых источниках
говорится, что Бен свободно заговорил на
китайском, хотя это, скорее всего, уже
преувеличение. Но удивительно здесь
другое. Бен переехал в Шанхай и стал
работать там гидом. Он устроился на
китайское ТВ и вёл шоу на китайском
языке. Hello,大家好,歡迎收看本期美南節目чал
преподавать английский китайским
студентом. Сам Бен уточнял, что после
пробуждения его китайский был на уровне
ребёнка, а свободно он начал им говорить
уже, переехав в Китай. То есть какого-то
мистического появления китайского языка
здесь всё же не было. И всё опирается на
личные субъективные показания Бена, а
значит, точнее, ничего сказать не можем.
Никаких тестов задокументировано. не
был. Другая удивительная история,
которая часто упоминается в СМИ по этой
теме. Хорватская тринадцатилетняя
девочка из города Кин, чьё имя не
разглашается из-за врачебной тайны,
попала в серьёзную автомобильную аварию
в апреле 2010. Тяжёлая черебно-мозговая
травма с кровоизлияние в мозг. Врачи
ввели её в искусственную кому на 24
часа. А когда она очнулась, первые её
слова были: "Где я? Что случилось? На
немецком языке. А что ещё удивляет, так
это то, что она забыла хорватский.
Врачам пришлось искать переводчика. В
данном случае родители подтвердили, что
девочка никогда не учила немецкий.
Психиатры проверили её на симуляцию
диссоциативное расстройство, ничего не
нашли. Девочка не притворялась,
раствоения личности не было. Стали
думать, как это возможно. Провели
дополнительные тесты и заметили, что у
девочки был австралийский акцент. И тут
родителей осенило. Она часто гостила у
дедушки, а дедушка смотрел австрийское
телевидение. Там она часто и видела
немецкие передачи. То есть мистики
никакой, но случай всё равно
удивительный. Мозг во время вот этой
стрессовой критической ситуации заменил
голос. Хорватский она забыла и
заговорила на спасительном немецком.
Неврологи из Загреба отмечали: "Это
редкий, но не уникальный случай". После
черепно-мозговой травмы мозг может
переключить языки, особенно если у
пациента был пассивный контакт с другим
языком. Через 2 недели она постепенно
начала вспоминать хорватский, но и
немецкий не забыла. Она так и осталась
Белин. Молодой британец Рори Кёртис из
Манчестер Юнайтед, на минуточку, в 2012
году попал в аварию. Рори врезался в
фургон, а в его машину врезалось ещё
шесть автомобилей. Врачи диагностировали
у парня кровоизлияние в мозг. После
аварии он впал в коп, а когда Рори
пришёл в себя, он, как утверждается,
заговорил на французском.
Здесь ситуация схожая. Он изучал
французский в школе, и мозг каким-то
образом достало воспоминания. Но в этой
истории удивляет другое. Рори, когда
проснулся, искренне верил, что он Мэтью
Макхонхи. Со временем эта вера
отступила, но в голове действительно
что-то ёкнуло. Он ушёл из футбола и стал
барбером.
Знаете, скажу честно, я очень много
случаев изучил вот этих вот человек
после комы заговорил на
древнеегипетском.
Это всё фейки. Ни одной нормальной
научной публикации, ни одного хорошо
задокументированного случая. Нету ни
одной публикации в авторитетном журнале
нигде. Имена выдуманные зачастую, и все
истории очень приукрашены. Но есть один
действительно подтверждённый медицинский
факт. Это синдром иностранного акцента.
Март 2010 года. Тридцатилетняя Сара
Колвел из Великобритании пережила острый
ишемический инсульт. Её отвезли в
отделение неврологии больницы Дэрифорд.
А проснулась она с ярко выраженным
китайским акцентом. Хотя она никогда не
жила в Китае, она никогда не учила
китайский язык. Люди, говорящие
по-китайски, да, утверждали, это
действительно китайский акцент. И тогда
доктора установили: повреждение мозга
привело к изменению артикуляций, что
случайным образом имитирует китайский
язык. У неё просто нарушилась речь. И
нарушилась она таким образом, что стала
похожа на китайский. Изменение
интонации, более пивучее произношение,
тонирование гласных, также укороченные
согласные. Женщина ещё 10 лет жила с
китайским акцентом, причём довольно
заметно. В магазинах её принимали за
иностранку. Ещё и наложился тот факт,
что она работала в кол-центре и ей
пришлось уволиться. И таких случаев
появления Акцента задокументировано
очень много, около 150 в мире. И все эти
случаи объяснить также можно. Но
непонятно, как быть с другими случаями.
Как быть с теми, кто утверждал, что
успел заглянуть в загробную жизнь?
Я не только нейрохирург, долгие годы
стоящий на стороне науки, но я ещё и
человек, который в середине своей жизни
пережил такое потрясение, что мне
пришлось перейти на другую сторону. Эбен
Александр родился в городе Шарлот,
Северная Каролина. Мальчик рос без
матери. Мать отказалась от него, когда
ему было 11 дней. Его отдали на
усыновление. Приёмным отцом Эбена стал
известный нейрохирург. Меня привлекала
научная сторона жизни моего приёмного
отца, и я также решил стать
нейрохирургом. Я провёл более 20 лет в
академической нейрохирургии. За это
время мной было сделано огромное
количество операций. Он написал полсотни
статей для научных журналов и выступал с
докладами на научных конференциях.
Доктор часто сталкивался с пациентами,
которые рассказывали ему о своих
видениях во время клинической смерти.
Кто-то видел родственников, кто-то видел
яркий свет, кто-то видел рай, кто-то
видел ангелов. И доктор всегда находил
объяснение: мозг умирает. Кто знает,
какие картинки он нарисует перед
смертью? Это уловка вашего мозга, чтобы
облегчить переживания в последние минуты
жизни. И объяснения у него всегда
находились до тех пор, пока он сам не
оказался на грани смерти.
10 ноября 2008 года. Я проснулся у себя
дома. Часы показывали 4:30. Я был
удивлён моему раннему пробуждению. Я
начал искать причину, что могло меня
разбудить. Наконец я решил встать с
кровати, но не смог этого сделать. Из-за
боли в спине я не мог двигаться. Но я не
хотел, чтобы моя жена вызывала скорую,
потому что ни один врач не желает быть
пациент.
Доктора отвезли в больницу, где он сам и
работает, и коллеги пытались понять, что
с ним происходит. А и Бену становилось
всё хуже и хуже до тех пор, пока он не
выкрикнул: "Господи, помоги мне!" И не
упал на пол в конвульсиях. Врачи ввели
его медикаментозную кому. Всё произошло
из-за редкой формы бактерии менингита.
Кора головного мозга была практически
отключена, а шансы на выживание
оценивались как крайне низкие. А спустя
7 дней Александр приходит в себя и
рассказывает нечто невероятное.
Сначала нейрохирургу показалось, что он
находится в так называемой грязной яме.
Время от времени там появлялись
искажённые лица каких-то существ. Они
издавали крик, а потом исчезали. Я был в
таком состоянии, когда я и не знал, кто
я. А так как у меня не было никаких
воспоминаний, мне казалось, что я всегда
был в этом месте и всегда буду в нём.
Затем он услышал свист и в мгновение
оказался в другом месте. Вися в воздухе,
я увидел перед собой зелёные луга, леса
и водопады. Я летел над всем этим, не
знаю куда. В какой-то момент я заметил
молодую женщину. Я чётко запомнил её
лицо. У неё были голубые глаза,
каштановые волосы. Она ничего мне не
сказала, но я понимал её мысли. Она
сообщила, что мне нечего бояться. Как
утверждал Александр, с этой женщиной,
врач путешествовал среди облаков,
общался с ангелами, которые сказали ему,
что существует непостижимое множество
вселенных с изобилием жизненных форм. В
каждой из этих вселенных есть зло. Оно
нужно для того, чтобы человек мог
свободно проявлять свою волю, без
которой невозможно его развитие. Когда
Александр проснулся, он не помнил своих
родственников вокруг, но зато прекрасно
помнил своё путешествие. Что касается
моего пережитого опыта, то я рассказываю
только те вещи, которые смог понять и
объяснить. Но есть многое, что мне пока
непонятно. Я полагаю, что и этим сложным
вещам будет дано научное объяснение. А
сейчас пока следует довольствоваться
ответом на простой вопрос. Наша душа
живёт вечно.
В двенадцатом году Александр выпускает
книгу Доказательство рая. Путешествие
нейрохирургов загробный мир. Слушайте, я
честно начал завидовать американскому
книжному рынку. Вы заметили, в каждой
истории, во всех моих роликах, чтобы ни
происходило, человек начинает писать
книгу своей жизни. И это очень круто,
потому что если так, значит, спрос есть,
значит люди читают, потому что у нас, у
меня такое ощущение, что идёт
бесконечное перепечатывание классики.
Классика просто постоянно в новой
обложке. Разумеется, история Александра
быстро нашли объяснение. В 2013 году в
журнале Squire, который я люблю всем
сердцем, была напечатана статья,
опровергающая некоторые утверждения из
книги. А ещё там напечатали ещё
неизвестную историю Эбена Александера.
Там говорилось, что его уволили и
отстранили от работы в нескольких
больницах, что на него подавали
несколько исков о врачебной халатности и
что за 10 лет он урегулировал пять исков
о врачебной халатности Вирджинии. В 2007
году он дважды за месяц, дважды
прооперировал не тот сегмент
позвоночника пациента, а в августе 2008
пациент подал на него суд с требованием
возместить 3 млн долларов. Но что нам
здесь более актуально - это семья
Александры. Как я говорил, приёмным
отцом Эбенна стал известный нейрохирург,
но, несмотря на это, он был очень
верующим человеком, как оказалось, и
очень религиозным. И это не могло не
отразиться на ребёнке. Известный
нейрхирург и писатель Оливер Сакс
говорил, что Александр, судя по всему,
не смог понять, что этот опыт мог быть
результатом восстановления функции коры
головного мозга в начале его комы, а не
сверхъестественным явлением. В 2012 году
Ин ответил критикам в статье Newsweek.
Он написал, что отчётливо помнит свою
галлюцинацию и вместе с тем отчётливо
помнит своё путешествие. И между этими
воспоминаниями была огромная разница.
Есть ещё одна загадочная деталь, которую
объяснить невозможно. После пережитого
опыта нейрохирург задался целью найти
своих биологических родителей, и он
сделал это. В 2007 году Александр
встретился с семьёй, братьями и
сёстрами, биологической семьёй. И тут
полная мистика. Он утверждает, что
родные родители сказали, что у него была
сестра, умершая ещё в девяносто восьмом
году. А когда он увидел фото своей
сестры, он узнал в ней лицо той самой
девушки, которую встретил на небесах.
Проверить это, разумеется, невозможно.
Доктора объясняют это всё теми же играми
нашего мозга. Александр мог просто не
помнить лицо, которое привиделось ему во
сне. И когда он увидел сестру, мозг
просто нарисовал аналогию.
Пин Ванломе. Нидерландский писатель,
провёл большое исследование в области
околосмертных переживаний. Цель проста:
проверить, являются ли околосмерные
переживания галлюцинациями или
свидетельством того, что наше сознание
существует вне тела. Также в
исследовании упоминались очень
загадочные случаи. Вот один из них. На
протяжении ночной смены скорая помощь
привезла сорокачетырёхлетнего мужчину.
Он уже был в коме. Когда мы собрались
интубировать пациента, оказалось, что у
него во рту были зубные протезы. Я сняла
его протезы и положила их на аварийную
тележку. Только после того, как прошло
больше недели, я снова встретил с
пациентом. Когда он меня увидел, он
сказал: "Эта медсестра знает, где мои
зубные протезы. Вы были здесь, когда
меня доставили в больницу, и вы достали
протезы у меня изо рта и положили их на
тележку за всеми этими бутылками. Там
был выдвижной ящик, и туда вы положили
мои зубы." Пациент утверждал, что он
видел себя, а медсестра говорила, что в
этот момент он был в глубокой коме. Его
глубоко впечатлили те переживания, и он
говорил, что больше не боится смерти.
Некоторые доктора предполагают, что в
момент угрозы жизни мозг активизирует
некоторые необычные формы восприятия.
Некоторые учёные утверждали, что всё это
результат аномальной работы мозга,
например, действие китамина или выброс
эндорфинов. Изучение явления
околосмертных переживаний подталкивает к
новому восприятию. Рассматривать мозг
скорее не как источник, а как приёмник
этих состояний. Ещё одно очень крупное
исследование ЭВ было проведено с 2008 по
2015 года. Проект возглавил британский
профессор медицины и специалист по
реанимации Сэм Парне. В исследовании
принимали участие 15 больниц
Великобритании, США и Австрии, а также
2.060 пациентов. Форneа выдвинул
гипотезу скрытого сознания. Даже при
отсутствии внешних признаков активности
некоторые нейронные сети могут
оставаться работоспособными. Более того,
в момент смерти выброс дофамина
увеличивается в 12 раз. Адофамин играет
важную роль в возбуждении, внимании,
познании, эмоциональных переживаниях.
Выброс серотонин увеличивается в 20 раз,
что, судя по всему, и вызывает у людей
зрительные галлюцинации с мистическими
чувствами. Многие пациенты рассказывали,
что их душа вышла из тела и наблюдала за
телом сверху. Тогда доктор решил
проверить это довольно простым методом.
В реанимациях на полках сверху он
расположил рисунки. Смотреть на них
можно было только сверху. сбоку их не
было видно. Если пациент буквально
говорит, что он мог летать над телом, то
и рисунки он точно увидит. Из всех
опрошенных, переживших клиническую
смерть, рисунки не увидел никто. Знаете,
задокументированы случаи самой
удивительной комы и самой длительной
комы. Начнём со второго. В 1970 году
шестнадцатилетняя Тер Эдуарда Абара не
смогла вовремя принять инсулин,
необходимый ей. И перед тем, как впасть
в кому, она успела сказать своей матери:
"Мама, не бросай меня". Мать в ответ
пообещала дочери, что никогда её не
оставла
обещание. Эдуарда пробыла в состоянии
комы 42 года. Самая длительная
задокументированная кома в истории
медицины. Кэтрин кормила дождь зонд,
постоянно переворачивала её, чтобы не
образовались пролежни. Общалась с ней,
включала ей музыку и фильмы. Но мама так
и не дождалась пробуждения дочери. Её не
стало в 2008 году в возрасте 81 года.
Она ждала всю свою жизнь, а Эдуарде не
суждено было проснуться. Спустя 42 года
комы она умерла. Самой же необычной
комой считают кому тридцатипятилетней
девушки из больницы во Вратславе,
Польше. Имя не разглашается из-за
врачебной тайны. И удивительно здесь то,
что на девятнадцатый день комы девушка
родила. Да, она поступила в больницу.
беременный, ребёнок выжил, девушка
осталась в коме. Вышла ли она из неё
позже, неизвестно. В общем, пока всё
сказанное можно объяснить. Почему люди
просыпаются с другим языком, почему
видят ангелов и так далее. Но вот один
удивительный случай, когда мужчина
утверждал, что после клинической смерти
он начал видеть будущее.
Это Днион Бринкли, вырос в Южной
Каролине США. В школе он был парнем так
себе. Дрался с одноклассниками,
хулиганил, был, скажем так, задирой. И
его характер поменялся. Поменялся 17
сентября семьдесят пятого года.
В Южной Королине бушевал ураган. Дениону
на тот момент было 25 лет. Он был дома,
разговаривал с другом по телефону как
неожиданно. Молния ударила прямо в крышу
дома, и разряд через телефонную трубку
прошёл прямо в ухо дни.
[музыка]
Скорее всего, молния попала в телефонный
кабель на улице. Сначала на мгновение
сильная боль, а затем пустота и
спокойствие. Дени он утверждает, что
смотрел на своё тело сверху. Он видел,
как родственники подбежали к нему,
пытались помочь, как приехала скорая. И
всё это время парень чувствовал
спокойствие. Ну а затем история, очень
схожая с историей нейрохирурга. Белый
туннель, по которому он нёсся, затем как
фильм он видел всю свою жизнь. Картинки
пробегали перед глазами. Только вот
теперь он оказался на месте тех, кого
обижал. Он видел те же самые ситуации из
школы, когда он был задир и только
чувствовал всё то, что чувствовали те,
кого он обижал. Он чувствовал боль
родителей, которые следили за его
поведением. Ну и всё то, что мы на самом
деле уже слышали в других историях.
Интересно здесь другое. Он утверждал,
что видел некую сущность. Она проводила
его в хрустальное строение. Там перед
ним было ещё 13 таких существ, и каждая
из них дала парню по коробке. В этих
коробках он видел события, которые
должны будут произойти в будущем. Он
пронёсся по всем этим событиям. Он видел
каждое, видел начавшиеся войны,
глобальные катаклизмы, экономические
кризисы. Когда Даниана откачали, он
пришёл в себя и, разумеется, написал
книгу. Там он поведал 117 предсказаний
будущего, и некоторые из них даже с
диалогами с этими существами. Вот один
из них. Это существо сказало парню: "Мы
рассматриваем каждого человека на Земле
как великого авантюриста. Вы
осмеливаетесь прийти на Землю, и в
сотворённом создателем мире в такой
сложной среде вы исполняете свои миссии.
Ваш человеческий род поистине герои, те,
кто спустились на Землю, настоящие
храбрецы. Вы вместе с Создателем
создаёте будущее". Отрывки из его книги
публиковали в The New York Times с
девяносто четвёртого года, а многие из
предсказаний сбылись, такие как люди
будут общаться через маленькие коробки
без проводов. Напомню, его ударило током
в семьдесят пятом году. Телефонов без
проводов тогда не было. Информация будет
передаваться по невидимым волнам, как
паутина. Предсказание интернета. Красная
империя рухнет без войны. Развал
Советского Союза. Америка подвергнется
атаке, и два высоких здания рухнут. Это
про 11 сентября. Стена, разделяющая
город подёт. Про берлинскую стену. Как
это объяснить? Во-первых, книга вышла в
девяносто четвёртом году. Время, когда
все вышесказанные предсказания уже
сбылись. И если честно, не совсем
понятно, добавили ли эти предсказания
уже в момент печатания книги или они
были до этого. Потому что, если увидеть
полный список предсказаний семьдесят
пятого года, мы увидим такие
предсказания: ядерная война между США и
СССР в восьмидесятых годах. Калифорния
уйдёт под воду в девяностых годах. В
девяносто восьмом году Китай вторгнется
в Россию. К 2000 году люди перестанут
есть мясо. Из всех предсказаний сбылось
только 30%. И неясно, когда эти 30%
появились. Действительно ли он сказал их
в семьдесят пятом или уже в девяносто
четвёртом? В общем, вера человека в
загробную жизнь, вера в ангелов,
сливаясь с незнанием природы нашего
сознания, выливается в такую картину.
Мозг действительно создаёт уникальные
прецеденты. Человек начинает говорить,
как будто с акцентом, забывает 40 лет
жизни, рассказывает об уникальных
галлюцинациях. Средства массовой
информации дорисовывают картину так, как
хочется им. Люди пересказывают истории,
и мы слышим истории на подобии человек
заговорил на древнегреческом. Мозг ещё
таит в себе огромное количество тайн. Мы
всё ещё не знаем, что такое наше
сознание. И кто знает, какие научные
открытия ждут нас впереди. M.